اعلن حاكم مقاطعه بريانس كالروسيه
المتاخمه للحدود الاوكرانيه مقتل شخصين في
اطلاق نار نفذتهما سماها مجموعه تخريبيه
اوكرانيه تسللت للمقاطعه واحتجزت عددا من
الرهائن بمتجر ومنازل في احدى قرى
المقاطعه وقد اكد الكريم لن ان الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين الذي وصف الحادثه
بالارهابي سيتراس الجمعه اجتماعا طارئا
لمجلس الامن القومي لبحث الهجوم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلاله السياق
وتوقيت هذه العمليه التي تعتبر الاولى من
نوعها في اطار الصراع الروسي الاوكراني
وما مدلولاتها لجهه سير الحرب على
اوكرانيا من الناحيتين الميدانيه
والعسكريه وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان نفهم هذا
التطور النوعيه في مسار هذا الصراع بين
موسكو على ضوء تسارع وتيره تسليح اوكرانيا
وتلويح روسيا بفتح جبهات جديده للحرب في
الربيع وما هي الانعكاسات المحتمله لعمليه
مقاطعه بريانسكا على استراتيجيه روسيا في
الحرب وكيف ستنظر اليها كييف وحلفاؤها
الغربيون
[موسيقى]
بحسب حاكم مقاطعه بريانس كالروسيه على
الحدود مع اوكرانيا فان اطلاق النار
نفذتهما سماها الحاكم مجموعه تخريبيه
اوكرانيه قال انها تسللت الى المقاطعه
اسفر عن مقتل واصابه مدنيين واضاف الحاكم
ان المجموعه احتجزت عددا من الرهائن في
متجر ومنازل في قريه اليوبشان
الرئيس الروسي ندد بالهجوم في بريانس
ووصفه بانه ارهابي واضاف بوتين في كلمه
متلفزه ان الجيش الروسي يحمل بلاده وشعبها
ممن سماهم النازيين الجدد والارهابيين
الذين تسللوا للاراضي الروسيه
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا الدكتور عمر
عاشور الساده الدراسات الامنيه
والاستراتيجيه وينضم الينا من عمان اللواء
فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
اسياده اللواء ما دلاله عمليه من هذا
النوع وان كان هناك نفي اوكراني ولكن في
كل الاحوال ماذا يمكن ان تكون دلاله عمليه
كهذه هي الاولى من نوعيها
العمليه الاولى من نوعها في هذه الحرب
ولكن عوده الى الحروب سواء في هذا القرن
او القرن الماضي نجد ان الحرب التي يطلق
عليها غير النظاميه هي سمه مرافقه
ومتلازمه مع الحرب النظاميه ولكن
الادوار الموكله لها وطبيعه المهام
وتاثيرها الفاعل هو الذي يختلف وفي عجاله
في اذا ذهبنا باتجاه الحرب العالميه
الثانيه ما اطلق عليهم احرار باري احرار
احرار فرنسا او احرار روسيا كانوا جزء من
العمليات العسكريه لكن تقوم بها قوات
عسكريه غير نظاميه في فيتنام
يمثل نفس الاتجاه في افغانستان لم يكن
هناك ذكر للجيش الافغاني كان هناك ذكر
للمجاهدين في الشيشان المقاتلين الشيشان
اذا حتى في العراق واحتلال العراق اذا
ظهور جماعات عسكريه عسكريه غير نظاميه هو
جزء من الحاله العامه هذه بالنسبه بصوره
عامه الان بصوره محدده من يقف وراء هذه
العمليه هناك اتهامات واتهامات مضاده
اتهامات روسيه الى اوكرانيا بان اوكرانيا
هي المسؤوله عن ذلك واتهامات اوكرانيه الى
روسيا بان روسيا هي من قامت بذلك والان
لنحدد هي الاطراف المقصوده والمعنيه في
حاله الاتهام الروسي نعم وجه الى اوكرانيا
ولكن قد يفسر بانه هل نفذها فيلق حريه
روسيا ام الفيلق الدولي ام الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه يقابل ذلك اوكرانيا تقول لا
نحن غير مسؤولين نفذت من قبل فاقنر او
الاستخبارات الروسيه لكن يبدو ان هناك
سيكون توظيف لهذه العمليه العمليه
اعتبرها جزء من الحرب في بناء او
استنادا الى الموروث التاريخي من الحروب
ولكنها ستوظف الان الرئيس بوتين قطع سياره
غدا هناك اجتماع يتحدث عن عمليه ارهابيه
اذا دعني اقول هذا الحادث لن يكون استثناء
لن يكون الاخير وبالتالي المهم التوظيف
السياسي
لهذا الحدث حتى تتضح الحقائق لماذا هذه
العمليه بهذه الطريقه هي عمليه مهمه وهل
بالفعل يمكن ان تشكل نقطه تحول بمعنى ماذا
يمكن ان يكون تاثيرها على ساحه الحرب
يا سيدي اعتقد لن يكون لها ذلك التاثير
الواضح على مجريات الحرب لكن قلت لك ستوظف
سياسيا من قبل القياده الروسيه بان الغرب
يدعم ارهابيين وستوظف من قبل الغرب بان
روسيا تفتح الاحداثا لاتهام الغير لكن
كتاثير يعني دعني اعيد مره اخرى الحرب غير
النظاميه الحرب اللام متناظره الحرب
الهجينه ثلاثه مسميات بثلاثه مراحل
تاريخيه الان
المصطلح العسكري المستخدم لوصف هذه الحاله
بانها تقع ضمن اطار الحرب الهجينه تنفذها
جماعات قد تكون منظمه ويطلق عليهم فدائي
يطلق عليهم مرتزق يطلق عليهم ثوره شعبيه
لكن الخطوره ليس في فقط في التوظيف
السياسي اذا اذا عدنا الى بعض اليوتيوبات
التي ظهرت وتحدث بعض اعضاء فيرق حريه
روسيا هم يتحدثوا عن امكانيه نقل العمليات
بصوره موسعه داخل العمق الروسي لتشكل
بدايه حرب اهليه
تتبناها الجماعات الناشده للحريه والساقطه
على القياده البروتينيه وهذا سر تخوف
الرئيس بوتين بانها قد تكون شراره انطلاق
نحو صدام اهلي روسي علما ان الحادثه اصغر
من ان توظف بهذا الاتجاه على الاقل في هذا
الوقت بالذات ما الفرقه في ان تكون الجهه
المنفذه هي الفيلق
الدولي او فيلق حريه روسيا او المخابرات
هل هناك اهميه للجهه التي يمكن ان تكون قد
نفذت العمليه
بكل تاكيد بكل تاكيد اذا نفذت من قبل فيلق
حريه روسيا فهذا ما سيقض مضاجع روسيا لان
فيلك روسيا 700 فرد معظمهم من الجنود
السابقين والذين رفضوا
الالتحاق بالتعبئه الجزئيه قسم منهم مقيم
على الاراضي الاوكرانيه يناشد بالحريه
يتحدثوا عن الظلم يتحدث عن اصدار قرار
بحكم عقوبه 15 سنه سجن لكل من يعارض ويدلي
بمعلومات اذا هي كانهم يعتبرها شراره
انطلقت باتجاه الداخل الروسي قد تفضي الى
حرب اهليه هذا في الجانب الاول في الجانب
الاخر الفيلق الدولي الفيلق الدولي نشا
بناء على طلب من الرئيسكي التحق به اعداد
كبيره من دول معظمها غربيه امريكا
بريطانيا ليتوانيا استونيا فرنسا المانيا
ايطاليا وهناك كانت دعوات على سبيل المثال
في السنغال يعني السفاره في
الاوكرانيه في السنغال بعثت بان تدعو
للالتحاق واحتجت السنغال على ذلك اذا وكلت
الى الفيلق الدولي فهذا يعني ان كافه
الدول الداعمه
لاوكرانيا هي دول داعمه للارهاب كما تتحدث
القياده الروسيه اذا التهمه الثالثه وجهت
الى الاستخبارات اصبحت الان نوع من تحقيق
الدعايه الروسيه فيما يتعلق بالناسيين
الاوكرانيين وانهم جماعات ارهابيه تتبنى
العنف اذا دعني اقول لكل حاله توصيفها
ولكل حاله
الظروف الخاصه
والتتاليات التابعه لها مستقبلا
عبر الهاتف منعنا الدكتور عمرو عاشور
ودكتور اسالك كيف تقرا انت هذا التطور وما
يمكن ان يكون له من تاثير
هو
تاثير عسكريا لا شيء
علميا ربما
وسياسيا واعلاميا
وربما يكون بعض الشيء
توجد
يعني معروف منها هؤلاء يعني لا يوجد
اسمائهم معروفه كيانهم كيان صغير للغايه
كتنظيم مسلح معروف
هم هم تقريبا شبه المستقلين الى الى حد ما
هم روت عرقيه يعني ليست
لا يمكن مقارناتها حتى بالعمليات القديمه
مثل 95 95 عمليه الشاميه الشهيره التي
اوقفت الحرب الشماليه الاولى لبلاطه
في في موسكو ولا غير ان العمليات الحجاز
لا يمكن مقارناتها بالمره
[موسيقى]
السابق الذي يعني
توجيه الاصابع ما بين
عرقيه
لكن المجموعه
العمليه ليست
للغايه الفريق الدولي
له مهمات معروفه للغايه وهو مؤطر في اطار
القوات الاحتياط
الاوكرانيه وما يقوم به معظم تقليديه
للغايه
لكن هو الغير موصل هو يمكن ان اتحكم حساب
افعاله
طبعا هذه العمليه تستغل في اطار الارهاب
ومكافحته وهكذا يعني لو
البعض يتكلم ايضا عن عمليات العالميه طبعا
هو حتى الان واضح لهذا غير واضح ان
العمليه على المزايا لكن كل الاقتراضات
موجوده لو عمليه عدم مزيفه
طبعا صعد الرئيس
شهيره في اليابان في 99
حينما كانت هناك محاولات تفجير مبنى سكني
القبضه على عاملين
القنبله
وطبعا هذه العمليه يعني كبيره ولكن انتهت
بحرب هشام وصعود
ابقى معنا دكتور طبعا يعني وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي نشرت صورا قالت انها لوحدات
روسيه تسمي نفسها الفيلق الروسي التطوعي
وتتبع القوات الاوكرانيه وقال المسلحون
الذين ظهروا في المقطع الذي نشاهده وانهم
موجودون في قريه
بمقاطعه براينز الروسيه لتحرير ارضهم
ودعوا الى حمل السلاح واعلان العصيان ضد
السلطات الروسيه
اوكرانيا التي قالت مخابراتها ان
المعلومات بشان ما يدور في منطقه بريانس
كاستمرار للتحول في روسيا وتنقيتها
وتحريرها من ديكتاتوريه بوتين على حسب
تعبيرها شككت على لسان المتحدث باسم
الاداره الاداره العسكريه لمقاطعه اوديسا
بوقوع العمليه من اصلها
من يقف وراء الاحداث في منطقه اذا ثبت
حدوثها بالفعل هذه استمرار لحمله الاكاذيب
والتضليل الروسيه لماذا لا تكون الروايه
هي ان مرتزقه وسجناء هم من قاموا بهذا
العرض الاستفزازي او ان تكون الروايه
الاخرى هي ان مجموعه من الاستخبارات
الروسيه قد ارتدت الزير الاوكراني ووضعت
شعارات صفراء واختلقت بعض الوثائق ودعت
انها اوكرانيا
يمكن ان تكون وراء عمليه من هذا النوع كما
يشير الاوكرانيون
يا سيدي لا نستطيع الجزم حتى هذه اللحظه
لان هذا الامر يحتاج بحث وتحليل وتقصي
ولكن هذه العمليات اذا كان هناك وراء لك
كما وراءها لا يمكن ان يتم اظهار الحقيقه
يعني اذا كانت فاغنر يعني
بالاصل مرتزقه قتل ماجورين 50,000 اربعين
الف منهم من ذوي العشبقيات الجرميه انا
هنا لا يعني لا احملهم المسؤوليه ولكن انا
اوصف الحاله بما انهم اصلا تم انتقائهم
واختيارهم بناء على اسبقيات جرميه عمليات
اغتصام مخدرات مقابل سته اشهر خدمه يتم
اعفائهم من بقيه المحكوميه ومقابل مكافات
ماليه تسند لهم المهام القذره واستخدمت
هذا المصطلح في مرات سابقه يعتبر راس
الحربه اذا كلفوا ذلك سيقوموا ولكن السؤال
الان هل سيقوم بتكليف من الحكومه الروسيه
بتكليف من قاعه قوات فاجنر لتحقيق معارف
سياسيه اذا دخلت الان عمليات العمل
المناكفات الداخليه والصراعات البينيه ما
بين قائد قوات فاجنر ورئيس الاركان ووزير
الدفاع في حارس الفوضى العامه يمكن حدوث
اي شيء لكن دعني اقول قد يكون المرجح
الاكبر فيلق حريه روسيا لماذا لانه
الاعداد 700 قتل منهم اعداد غير معروفه في
الخطوط الاماميه يقاتل في باك موت لديهم
قناعات معينه لديهم حديث حول الحريه وحول
الديكتاتوريه
الضاغطه والكابته للحريه وبالتالي قد يكون
هو الارجح ان ان نفذ من قبل فيلق حريه
حريه روسيا
لاستبعد ان تكون الانظمه وراء هذا العمل
لانه عمل موصوف بالقذاره ويمكن كشف هذه
علما انا ستحاول اذا ما تبنتها ان تغطي
وتقطع طريقه تحقيقات لكن دعني اشير هذا
الحادث يبقى حادث محدود ما لم يكن تم
تبنيه من قبل فيلق حريه روسيا هنا الخطوره
على روسيا اذا نفذ من قبل اي جانب اخر
سيتم تعطير التاثير وعدم حدوث امتدادات
لكن اذا نفذ بايادي روسيه من قبل فيرق
حريه روسيا وكما يتحدث عن انها ستكون
بدايه الطريق الطويل نحو حرب اهليه هذا هو
الامر المفزع للقياده الروسيه دكتور عمر
هل هذا يعني احد الاهداف لاوكرانيا
وحلفائها ان يتحول الامر الى حرب روسيه
روسيه في داخل الروسي
غير متاكد من هذا هو طبعا هناك
بشكل اخراجها لتحديد اراضي الاوكرانيه
وانتهى الامر على هذا
الاوكرانيه ومنقطعه حوالي اربعه مقاطعات
اجزاء من اربعه مقاطعات جمهوريه
2014 وبالتالي
هذا هو الوضع اضعاف موجود بالطبع لكن هذه
العمليه للجانب الاوكراني اظن لها لن تفيد
في اي شيء ولهذا هو هو ينكر يعني اي اي
مصلحه له فيها
الاثار اثرها على البعض الاعلامي والسياسي
فتشتغل
اكيد
يتحول الامر من مواجهات عسكريه تقليديه او
حتى غير نظاميه على التحرير للارض هذا
امرض مشروع ومقنن اما لو تحول لارهام
وارهاب داخل الدوله
[موسيقى]
بعمليه كبيره في الربيع
يا سيدي يعني نحن نتحدث عن بعدين مختلفين
قد يكون هناك بينهما بعض التواصل او
الارتباط عندما نتحدث عن هجوم الربيع
ونتحدث عن تسليح الغربي نتحدث عن تسليح
موجه الى الحكومه الاوكرانيه الى الجيش
الاوكراني تزويده بالسلاح تدريب الجنود
الى غير ذلك عندما نذهب باتجاه هذا الحادث
نحن نذهب باتجاه الحرب كما قلت لك غير
المتناظره او الحرب غير النظاميه او الحرب
الهجينه حسب المصطلح الامريكي ان تقوم
جماعات معينه
لديها ايدولوجيه معينه لديها هدف معين
بتنفيذ هذا العمل بطريقه غير تقليديه قد
تستخدم السلاح التقليدي وتوظف بطريقه غير
تقليديه ما هو يعني الان كيف تستخدم
السلاح التقليدي بطريقه غير تقليديه
تستخدم اسلحه يمكن الحصول عليها من طرق
مختلفه من السوق السوداء من اي جهه اخرى
وتستخدمها ضد اهداف لينه اهداف رخوه
تستخدمه المتفجرات تهاجم مدنيين تقد تهاجم
مدارس مستقبلا قد تهاجم حضارات اطفال اذا
دعني اقول هي الحرب غير تقليد تستخدم
السلاح التقليدي بطريقه غير تقليديه
لمهاجمه اهداف لينه الدكتور عمر عاشور
عاشور هل لهذه العمليه اي تاثير على
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه او
الاوكرانيه او يمكن ان نعتبرها مؤشرا على
ذلك في اي حال من الاحوال
لا اظن اظن على الجانب الروسي
اي نوع من المقاومه وخصوصا القوات الغير
النظاميه السابعه لاوكرانيا على انها قوات
ارهابيه هي تفعل ذلك من البدايه يعني
الهجوم الذي سبق عمليه التقليد الذي حدثت
في في المطار
الجوي العسكري جنوب في بيلاروس من ايام
عمليه تقليد ارهابيه
وفي المناطق القريبه
كذلك لكن هي كانت كلها تستهلك اقوال جويه
او مطارات او قطارات عسكريه وكانت الهدف
عسكري بشكل كبير اما هذه
الارهاب لا شك فيه
على الجانب الروسي سيتم يعني استخدام هذا
على جانب الاوكراني هو لا يحتاجون الارهاب
يعني يعني تكتيكات الارهاب حين تكون في
وضع وضع طبق اضعف واعترف مح بط الجانب
الاوكراني لا هو في وضع هو يعني
يقوم هجوم جيد ويحضر الهجوم تحليل اراضي
ومدعوميا بشكل مكثف وستصل في مستقبل
القريب عربات قتاليه المزيد من المدرعات
وربما يصله اكثر من ذلك
شكرا جزيلا دكتور عمر عاشور استاذ
الدراسات الامنيه والاستراتيجيه في معهد
الدوحه للدراسات العليا واللواء فايزه
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر شكرا لكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]